我建議大家可以把自己工作和生活的片段以及自己對這個世界的理解
塞出來
重建出來
就它們的口裁沒關係
和你是不是口土聯話
沒關係
統一點無所謂這個世界最重要的最吸缺的是
真實
這裡沒有兩個要點
一個就是
活出自己
第二的話就是長事的吧
塞出來
這個開門開了有一句話就是
如果你有一千個真實粉絲你可以生活得很好
很多社群都會說到自己的話的影響
據說
占好容易說到自己的話的影響做了內館
社會軟接
而且在照片的時候的話
還側面通過各種
方式
來獲知你是否多我開門開了一個東西
如果多的話他會優先
出去
但是我不建議普通人注意
我說的是普通人我不建議普通人
去學所謂的什麼
派說我要去學那些所謂的套路
沒有任何意
但有興趣可以看一下
就是很多
百萬或者千萬
大臂
他們的很多視頻
點贊都沒有超過一千
什麼意思點贊都不願意點贊
更何況成為你真實的粉絲了
就不要被那個
所謂我們說的粉絲不是這個
比如說像我個人來說三百多萬粉絲
其實我真實的粉絲
大概是三千人左右
如果沒有真實的粉絲所以他不在那個量
有可能你可能只有
兩千個粉絲但是我一千個真實的粉絲
活出你自己
就不要模仿他人
注意我說這個模仿不是不要去學習
就我之前一直跟他說
零國零模
那個零模是要去學習他人
但是你要活出你自己
很多是涉嫩的
我這個會贏我那個不行
我自己影響最大的一次是什麼呢
就承認我再一次軟監套的大會上
裡面的很多程序
我要去說現象
我突然突發現象我就買了一個頭頭
就是有頭頭帶手
然後那次感覺非常害
我沒有多想
裡面對程序按摩
你可能我做這樣的事情
大會怎麼看
沒想過
我覺得這樣很苦
結果後來我發現很多人上台都帶著我的那個頭頭
所以我就明白了一件事情人一定要學會做自己
不要給自己涉嫩
我們好朋友來到這個市場一樣
為什麼不多自己呢
然後如時的
呈現自己
就好了
比如說你是個廚師
那你做認真的去
做好一盤的紅燥肉
讓大家看到你做紅燥的過程
如時的給大家去
分享
或者讓大家看到你是怎麼工作的
你呈現的結果
讓大家看到
你工作的狀態
你的用心你的專注
可能是那個產品
哇
可能是一種興奮感
可能是一種創新
可能是一種價值
但是人們在你這裡有所得
不斷的去
傳遞
這種
價值
這個世界上的話
那怕你在古怪
總會有一些人和你是同平的
我當然不知道
沒有聽過這個廚房的故事
所以有個老師讓大家畫了一個
模特兒
一個非常漂亮而且深裁非常好的女模特兒
結果的話呢這個主人工
代為
畫了一個廚房外
就是這個
深裁特別
然後手腳特別
細小
就臭外
然後看完以後的話呢這個老師就很生氣
說你畫得太臭了
然後這個代為就不服
那我臭也可以是中美
但老師的畫的不喜歡這款作品
但是那個模特兒很喜歡
兩個人就
同品吧
但是整好發生了九條幼視鏡
然後這個女孩都到就回到韓國女孩的韓國
兩個人就開始熟悉
男孩的畫面每次顯然性都是
畫了一個臭外
然後這個女孩的畫呢
畫來就給他做了個滿火
就氣回去了
男孩的哪個男孩的哪個男孩的寶特選擇
他的朋友看到之後很喜歡
說去找這個女孩的訂購吧
就訂了一些
然後在各個地方
買結果份子越來越多
這就是那個臭瓦了
出現了很多的用品用是作品的那邊
後來阿嬤就是去白宮的時候
還管了他
大家知道這個事情吧
所以你會發現
總有一些人和你的觀點
是一樣的
然後因為你活出了你自己
別人會給你點贊
主要這個點贊不是我們說的那個點贊
而是為你的生活
為你的生活太多為你的作品點贊
所以各位
兩件事情
第一 活出自己
好不容易大家的這個世界一次
一定要活出自己
第二 如實的
真實是這個實際上最多力量的東西
通過
才是我們的特色
真實到呈現我們的生活中來
你會發現你能
收获到很多一項不到的東西